hoy el mundo superó las 3 millones de
muertes por kobe 19 y en todo el planeta
se han contagiado ya más de 140 millones
de personas a un año y un mes después de
que la oms se declarara la pandemia el
organismo alerta de que está lejos del
fin alrededor del mundo los casos y las
muertes siguen al alza a una velocidad
preocupante globalmente el número de
casos por semana se ha duplicado en los
últimos dos meses lo que se acerca a la
mayor incidencia de infección que hemos
visto en toda la pandemia
mientras algunos países pro siguen con
una masiva campaña de vacunación
regiones como la latinoamericana la más
afectada por el virus vive críticas
situaciones sanitarias lejos de alcanzar
la inmunidad de la población
particularmente brasil y méxico- son el
segundo y el tercer país del mundo con
más fallecidos por kobe 19 brasil
acumula más de 370.000 muertes es decir
una décima parte de los decesos
mundiales por coronavirus el temor por
la expansión de la llamada variante
brasileña ha llevado a distintos países
como francia colombia y bolivia a cerrar
sus fronteras con el gigante
latinoamericano
por otro lado argentina alcanzó una
cifra récord de contagios diarios con 29
mil nuevos casos registrados en 24 horas
el gobierno de alberto fernández decretó
toques de queda y cierre de las escuelas
en la región de la capital lo que
desencadenó en protestas en las calles
de buenos aires el argentino es un
ejemplo paradigmático del dilema que
supone imponer medidas para salvar vidas
mientras agoniza la economía según el
informe anual de amnistía internacional
ocho millones de personas han caído en
la pobreza extrema durante el primer año
de pandemia en la región latinoamericana